/ una jornada de definiciones con la
clasificación de ecuador y uruguay a
esta semana resurrecciones como la de
colombia y grandes decepciones como la
eliminación del campeón de europa y
cuatro veces ganador de la copa del
mundo italia para analizar lo sucedido
esta semana y lo que nos espera la
próxima está con nosotros ara castro
directora de deportes de caracol radio y
del diario 'as' colombia bienvenida a
sara gracias por estar con nosotros hola
marc buenas noches como siempre es un
gusto regresar aquí a hablar de fútbol
bien ahora comenzamos
conversando sobre el más inesperado de
los resultados la eliminación de italia
a manos de macedonia del norte que nos
dice esto del momento que está
atravesando el fútbol italiano sin duda
hablamos de dos temas fue una parte
decisiones coyunturales del técnico
mancini que no no pudo resolver algunos
algunas de las bajas que tuvo durante la
eliminatoria en este último partido se
formó mucho un sistema de juego
pero de fondo estamos hablando de temas
estructurales en el fútbol italiano por
un lado estamos hablando de equipos a
nivel de clubes que no han logrado
conseguir ningún triunfo en a nivel
europeo desde 2010 una falta de
promoción del talento juvenil y de fondo
también estamos hablando que esta
reconstrucción del fútbol italiano
pasando del catenaccio de este fútbol
defensivo a esta nueva propuesta de
mancini sin duda va a necesitar tiempo y
los proyectos deportivos si bien
empezaron con pie derecho ganando la
eurocopa
necesitan tener digamos que una
inmersión cultural no entrar a ser parte
de la identidad de este fútbol y sin
duda yo creo que esta decisión de
gabriel gravin ha de mantener a mancini
al frente de la selección aunque él no
ha decidido si va a continuar es
importante es importante porque sólo
estos procesos sostenidos y mantenidos
en el tiempo son los que pueden empezar
a dar resultados insisto es un cambio
cultural profundo es un cambio que tiene
que ver con lo que pasa sale el calcio y
en como esta nueva estructura de fútbol
se adapta un modelo que está cambiando
no sólo no sólo en el fútbol italiano
sino a nivel europeo más idónea del
norte para ahora contra portugal que
podemos esperarnos de este partido en
particular y de lo que queda por
definirse en europa que depende en gran
medida de la contingencia
geopolítica no bueno yo creo que lo de
macedonio es difícil que se repita no
ahora en el fútbol nada está escrito que
fue lo que propuso macedonia un bloque
abajo un bloque muy bien parado un
equipo defensivo y evidentemente en esta
transición italiana ellos no lograron
ser profundos y generar opciones de gol
claras hay que decir de éste portugal
que es una muy buena generación de
jugadores siempre se habla de cristiano
ronaldo del hombre récord evidentemente
un líder y un jugador que va a marcar
diferencia pero estamos hablando de
jugadores como diego yo está como
bernardo silva joao cone canceló es
decir este es un equipo que no sólo
tiene un proceso largo
con un director técnico el que lo ha
sostenido desde aquella eurocopa sino
que también estamos hablando de un
equipo que seguramente y a partir de lo
que vio del partido frente a italia va a
poder encontrar esas soluciones tácticas
para poder hacerle daño a un equipo que
evidentemente lo que va a intentar es
mantener el cero la mayor parte del
partido la posición de italia frente a
macedonios o del 65 por ciento es decir
italia siempre tuvo la pelota ahora lo
que hay que encontrar es como ser
incisivos y eficaces a la hora de tener
opciones de goya vamos a vivir también
una jornada interesante en sudamérica
con tres equipos tratando de conquistar
ese último cupo para el repechaje cuál
es la perspectiva que nos espera y que
nos quien lectura podemos hacer de lo
que ha sido toda esta eliminatoria
sudamericana lo primero es que la
primera opción la tiene pero
evidentemente que juega en su casa que
recibe a paraguay paraguay una selección
que le ha costado mucho que incluso con
la llegada de guillermo barros schelotto
no logró resultados pero que sorprendió
en la última jornada goleando ecuador y
esto nos habla de fondo de una
eliminatoria terriblemente regular más
allá de la distancia que lograron sacar
brasil-argentina que tienen proyectos y
procesos muy bien formados una idea de
que se ha construido a lo largo del
tiempo escalón y es un buen ejemplo de
cómo un proceso y una idea de juego
sostenida puede dar resultados
pero tuvo muchos problemas durante la
eliminatoria sobre todo en el inicio
pero por ejemplo le sacó 6 puntos tanto
en casa como visitante a colombia y eso
es lo que nos lo mantiene hoy con esta
primera opción si ellos ganan van entran
por ese cupo al repechaje colombia tuvo
unos muy difíciles partidos siete
partidos sin ganar más de 640 minutos
sin anotar gol y se enfrenta además al
hombre que mejor conoce a esta
generación
18 de estos 28 jugadores que fueron
convocados por esta fecha eliminatoria
estuvieron con josé pekerman durante su
paso con la selección colombia así que
ese partido en puerto ordaz va a ser
bastante complicado ya vimos un
venezuela que también paró un equipo que
le puso las cosas difíciles argentinas
por lo menos en los primeros 30 minutos
del primer tiempo así que para el equipo
de reinaldo rueda va a ser va a ser
complicado ahora bien yo creo que se
encuentro con pekín o puede ser una
mirada en el espejo para recordar lo que
ha sido esta selección colombia y una
vez conseguido ese es ese resultado pues
esperar lo que pasa en los otros
escenarios bien te agradecemos muchísimo
usar haber compartido este análisis con
nosotros